anthropic raises 124 million for
steerable ai peer review is threatened
by collusion rings
and the original eliza source code was
discovered
this and much more in ml news
[Applause]
hello and welcome to ml news your
absolutely
irregular update of what happens in the
ml world
i thought i'd try something new and if
you like this format let me know if you
don't like this format let me
know even more please so we're going to
go over a bunch of stories of what
happened
in the last week or so in the ml world
and the first
story here is that anthropic techcrunch
writes
the new ai research company by
daario amodei of openai and his sister
daniela amonde is a new startup
that focuses by their own website on
reliable
interpretable and steerable ai systems
they have raised 124 million dollars in
a series a
round led by jan talin the co-founder of
skype and other people such as eric
schmidt
and dustin moskowitz their press release
says
anthropic's goal is to make the
fundamental research advances that will
let us build more capable general and
reliable ai systems
then deploy these systems in a way that
benefits people
and the research principles center
around ai
as a systematic science safety and
scaling
and developing tools and measurements to
measure our advance towards
general or capable ai that benefits
everyone
if you think that sounds a little bit
like open ai sounded at the beginning
you're very correct if you go back to
the very first blog post of open ai
introducing open ai it sounds
a lot similar saying that ai should be
as broadly and evenly distributed as
possible in the spirit of liberty
and so on now other than open ai
anthropic by the way it's not anthropic
ai as
i understand it's just anthropic
anthropic is not a non-profit
and i'm pretty sure the investors do
expect a return on their money
even though the company focuses on
research initially
so while it sounds very much like open
ai i would expect that anthropic
does shoot towards some profitable
venture in the future
so maybe at least when they say it
should benefit everyone we might expect
that
if they ever release an api at least
that will be open
to anyone yeah remember those times
where the repositories of open ai said
the checkpoint is available
at this link i guess we're going to see
what happens i'm mainly excited
about another group of capable people
coming together
and doing something different they have
a lot of careers open
and if you see yourself in any of these
roles don't hesitate to
apply i guess though i don't want to
rack too much on openai their
track record in their projects is pretty
impressive and a lot of what they've
done has contributed to the greater ai
world
in a very very beneficial way i'm still
happy that open ai exists rather than it
didn't
so good job everyone
[Music]
next news 65 of execs can't explain
how their ai models make decisions
survey finds
venturebeat writes that a new survey
from
fico and corinium surveyed a hundred
c-level analytic and data executives to
understand
how organizations are developing ai and
apparently 65
of them can't explain how ai model
decisions or predictions are made
which of course is used by people to
bring the warning bells
and say well we don't understand ai
but remember these are c-level
executives they don't even understand
how an excel
spreadsheet makes its decisions and they
don't need to
so make of this as you will if you want
to go and read the whole
study survey and the report i'll link it
in the description it's pretty
interesting honestly
and obviously it is important that we do
understand
why ai makes the decisions it does
[Music]
next news deepmind releases android n
the android learning environment this
is pretty cool it builds on top of the
android emulator
and it gives unified descriptions of the
interface
and tasks so that you can do
reinforcement learning
on android apps so there's many
possibilities here
you can do multitask learning because
you use different apps you can do
perception because you need to actually
see the screen
there is a lot of opportunity to hard
code things not to hard code things to
learn
gestures and potentially you can
interact with any app that runs on
android so this is pretty cool and it is
a cool bridge
in between the real toy environments
that we have
until now to something like robotics in
the real world where you need
lots of time and you can't just reset
all the time
and an android operating system is
actually something that people
interact with every day so they do
provide this on
github and they do provide a bunch of
example tasks such that you
see how you can build your own if you're
interested in reinforcement learning and
the bridge to the real world and maybe
robotics
i think this would be a good start it's
cool to see something from deepmind
again that is rather
open source the apps that are already
there come in a variety
from maps to the browser to a little
games
and apparently even the battle of
polytopia
is integrated as a wait a minute
oh come on well at least the rest is
open source
there is a technical report if you're
interested go
read it check out the github repo
and let's go on now the remote is so
great
collusion rings threaten the integrity
of computer science
research warns michael l littman in an
article
at the communications of the acm a
collusion ring is essentially a bunch of
people that secretly work together
bid on each other's papers and then
write
positive reviews about these papers in
the conference
review process they also lobby other
reviewers
and area chairs in order to accept these
papers
so the colluders give each other
positive reviews with the hope that
their papers get accepted without being
of proper quality
apparently the author of this article is
aware that this
is happening at one of the large machine
learning conferences
though they do not give the name of the
conference or
of the colluders the article is mainly
to
raise awareness about the existence of
the problem
and i'm sure if they're aware of
something this is not the only collusion
ring in fact
i am aware of a lot of shady practices
in the reviewing system i know shocking
discovery if you couple
the anonymity of peer review with the
super intense pressure of getting
published you'll get shady behavior
and our last story joseph weitzenbaum's
original
source code for the eliza program was
discovered
eliza of course the program we all loved
sparking
humanity's interest in ai and then
absolutely failing to live up to that
standard
so jeff schrager writes here that the
original source code
was discovered in the archives
of mit now if you expected a github repo
i'm sorry to disappoint you
this is a scan of a personal folder
where the source code is pasted it is
implemented
in a language called math slip and its
most successful application
is the so-called doctor script that
implements a rogerian therapist
based on the conversational principles
of carl rogers
rigerian conversation essentially means
that you restate the opinions
of your conversational partner until
your conversational partner agrees that
you have properly understood them
this can be used in a therapeutic
context
in order to reflect people's opinions
back upon them and elaborate
more so there are many online
implementations
of something like eliza that you can
play around with
so this one for example if i type in i'm
sad it asks me did you come to me
because you are sad
yes that's why i came here
what is it that you really want to know
i'd
like to know why
banana taste
sour after drinking
tea why do you ask
as you can see this is a sort of a regex
type
script what it does is it looks at what
you're saying
and then it sort of replaces this into
some pre-canned responses
and then it has some other modes like if
you
say i'd like to know it responds with
why do you ask
if you say no it asks why are you
negative
and so on so it's sort of a pattern
matching algorithm and people were
really excited about this
at the beginning but then of course the
brittleness
of the system comes to bear really
quickly because all it can do is sort of
reflect
back onto you what you've already said
now don't get me wrong carl rogers was
not advocating
for an approach like this this is simply
a part of the approach
rogers was actually a quite competent
person
and i think his approaches are used
successfully all over the world until
today
so in the source code you're going to
see the
regexes or patterns that eliza
uses you're going to see the
substitutions and
what it responds to followed by the
actual
implementation of the program itself
so if you want to dive into something
other than pytorch
and tensorflow knock yourselves out
and it's yannick from the future i
almost forgot openai
is opening a 100 million
dollar fund to help ai companies have a
profound positive impact
they want to spread it very thick so
they only want to invest
in a small number of early stage
startups in the field
where artificial intelligence can have a
transformative effect
like healthcare climate change and
education though
the application form is just open so
you can apply if you want some piece of
that
100 million dollars go for it
yay
okay that was it for this week's ml news
maybe there's gonna be one next week
who knows there's no schedule here tell
me
if you like this and tell me what you
think about the individual things
go raise yourself 124 million for your
own ai company
i'll see you next time
you